it's been a good few months since I've
been here the outside looks different
the front door I'm excited to see the
back so uh let's go
[Music]
this looks amazing
my goodness
[Music]
wow a little bit yes you've done this to
a really high
oh my God I don't know how to do I love
it show me around
[Music]
doing this it's just shopping and
playing house yeah so yeah and I
remember as well when you first bought
this there was loads of challenges in
terms of oh you're not going to be able
to do this you're not gonna be able to
do this a lot of yeah challenges all
sorts you know everything I argue the
toss over everything everyone was like
these banisters are terrible you've got
to get rid of them and answer like no if
a panel this side
you've got a vision
um how has it gone is it gone to budget
uh I've gone slightly over but my end
value has gone massively up so show us
around exciting so
this was the original kitchen if you
remember how disgusting that was so kept
this is an office I was gonna knock
right through but everybody wants a home
office now so decided why
um oh my goodness this is ridiculous
I can't even remember what it was like
before now my mind has just completely
gone mad where did it end before here
so oh my goodness here bay window that
they went back when I last came you were
just beginning to to put this is crazy
value added here yeah this is what
people want though we don't ever want
they want an island kitchen every time
the space I love these doors did you do
this on permitted development yes she
didn't even need to get planning
permission no no because yeah I got a
lawful development certificate so that
when I sell how far back it's got to be
about four meters yeah you can go on a
detached you can go for me it's barely
even detached though
honestly there was like yeah there's no
side windows on that side yeah oh it's
built right to the boundary but
technically it's detachable you can do
four you can do I was nearly caught out
because I was going to do two stories
which you can do on permitted on a
detached but you have to be a meter away
from your side boundary I had only read
about your end boundaries yeah and I
nearly could have come on stop there
this is so good this is so nice are you
living in this at the moment
I can't wait to find out the figures and
what you're doing with it but first
let's have a look
so little
um utility
it's just got so much space hasn't it
yeah I love how you've utilized the
space and you you know what you've
thought you've thought about I don't
know if you're going to be continuing to
live here and stay here or if you're
selling it or what but you've been
thinking what do people want people want
a big kitchen yeah so you've done the
extension there they want an island
people want a little home office yeah
downstairs so we took the back door away
yeah and made a little you do a lot
you've done a lot tried to give it
everything it's
oh lovely front room lovely carpet as
well just really homely isn't it
amazing here's what everybody's you're
looking for they're like a front room
separate but then the big family thing
it's a proper family home this but
everything's good and you bought this
for 250
242 and a half 242 and a half
and you spent how much on it 77. so all
in 310 but you were saying like next
door was like 390. yeah so all right
well show me upstairs and then we're
gonna go into more figures
and I like the color I like the color
coordination I just yeah I like this
this works we're going to be doing this
in my house actually we're putting
Carpets on the wooden stairs the colors
it just works it's nice if you can do
the rub the stairs and stuff but you
have to draw the line yeah on the
project okay so front bedroom bay window
nice yeah and this has just literally
been knocked back to bread and you had
some serious problems as well yeah I had
to have the chimneys all taken down so I
didn't just cap them I took them off
below the roof and retiled over this has
been fully tanked so it had the mesh
with the plugs re-plasterboarded yeah
all insulated and reposted and there was
like a lot of leaking and stuff going on
here as well absolutely yeah dripping
work so it's all now sorted done done
surveyed yeah approved ever since yeah
well it looked great too amazing love
the love the windows and the view I like
the street as well the thing is as well
I always say this but the thing you
can't change About Properties the
location yeah and if you buy the worst
house on the best street which is what
you did yeah but then turn it to the
best house on the best street that's
when you really create value and it's a
great Street it's a lovely part of
Stockport and now it's a lovely family
home it is yes and it hasn't been
touched but I think she was in 70 years
the lady wow
and then this is it would be your master
bedroom
okay
you did it I did you did everyone said
you can't do it I know I'm a stickler
and you did it literally oh my goodness
it's big enough to do it but yeah
everyone said no no all the builders
yeah
even I was thinking
is she gonna do it yeah you did it so
this so basically you've what the heck
how have you managed to do that well
there was a landing here this Landing
came round and there was a door into the
so you've finished mixed some of the
landing and put it into part of the
bathroom yeah to make this just because
this is quite adequate as well yeah yeah
yeah yeah let's do something and that
was this then what was it there was what
was here so I'm trying to remember now
so that would have been the wall and a
toilet and then the other side was a
door here so it knocked all this down I
hate the space bigger turned this into
its own bathroom yeah and then nicked
the back of the bathroom oh sweet
I had my tick list thank you high five
so go girl that is crazy and the room's
big and look at this and this is
different what's going on so I didn't
want a flat roof on the expression
because I wanted it vaulted when you're
in the you know when you're downstairs
yeah why did you why did you want it
vaulted just the size it just when you
walk in you've got more and then but
then everybody said well then you'll
have to lose your Bay and have a flat
window here yeah I was like yeah that's
not happening
um so the roof
structure is under here right because it
you know to get the slope it had to come
into here and join on this wall you know
what if you weren't so successful in
property I would totally hire you as a
project manager on all of my projects
because that is just ridiculous I mean
and an allotment at the back I love it I
can't believe you've done this entire
thing for 77 Grand I know so you bought
it for 242 you spent 77 Grand on it so
all I know that's how much
[Music]
319.
so you last time we met you were talking
about keeping it and refinancing it
because if you refinance that you you'd
pull out all your money yeah yeah you'd
be left with a free house yes
um
but I I remember I still I still hold to
it yeah you thought I'd done a high-end
look on that I should sell it yeah yeah
so you are selling it though sold it
sold it yeah
yeah okay so hold on you said that you
wanted to sell it for
385 to 400. it's an interesting Market
yeah if you don't mind me asking what
did you sell it for and you have to
guess I have to guess oh
let me go downstairs okay and I'll guess
okay I'm hoping close to 400 at least oh
I'm saying I don't think you'd want to
make less than 100 Grand profit because
on how much work you've put into this so
I don't think you'd let it go for a
minimum 420. we are in a booming-ish
market but obviously there's a lot of
changes that have happened the last few
weeks cash buyer
I'm saying you sold it for maybe four
two five
450. oh nice that's a good price yeah I
had I actually had
um several offers like 20 grand over
and I wasn't at the P you know I was
worried I'd left it a bit too late how
much profit will you make then on this
130 500. was it worth the work
what are you gonna do with the money do
it again do it again have you got any
more houses that you've recently bought
or buying I I bought a flat nice so
that's gonna be a nice little one-time
yeah bigger deals now though I do
bringing me in some cash flow whilst I'm
doing them so you could do it up as a br
maybe it's a service department yeah
okay yeah so listen you've been in
property now for like over 20 years kind
of doing bits and Bobs now you're sort
of scaling up talk to me about your
advice for people watching this
just it's always a good time doesn't
matter the Market's Rising falling
there's deals to be had the thing is to
get the training so you know you can
stack the figures and you know it's a
good deal and for me that's I needed
that for the confidence I needed to be
able to know myself I'd have an inkling
like oh I'm sure I could make money on
that but then it's a risk so it's the
confidence thing being able to sit and
do my own figures and not be relying on
other people to tell me it could make
money to have that confidence and that I
got through your training well and
that's the environment of the right
people yeah around like Cameron yeah
yeah Cameron's like making like half a
million pound on every game he's doing
big development deals so I'm really
impressed with what you've done to get
ray I look forward to seeing your scale
up big if you want to do the same
comment down to the property investors
crash course it costs how much a pound a
pound come and spend a day with me let's
do business I'll leave a link in the
description see you next time
[Music]